a fearless future chief a crazy rooster
and an egotistical demigod as if some of
the cool characters you'll find in moaña
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
so what else can you expect from
Disney's latest animated feature well
when it comes to animation Moana is
truly beautiful there's a lush nough
stew the islands and everything looks
suitably inviting at least when it's
meant to especially the ocean which even
takes on its own playful personality
throughout the film and there are also
some gorgeous sequences which have a 2d
animated handmade textured feel to them
which I really loved when it comes to
bringing to life the movies lead
character newcomer Ally Carvalho gives a
fabulously spirited and engaging
performance as the adventurous teen
Moana and wow she can really carry a
tune as she more than shows with her
rendition of the soon to be classic how
far I'll go Dwayne Johnson has the bags
of personality and presence needed to
pull off the role of the super full of
himself shape-shifting demigod Maui
Johnson is wonderfully funny delivers
his lines with great gusto and gets one
hell of a song and the very catchy or
welcome and together crevalle owen
johnson make a lovely onscreen double
act sharing some nice back and forth as
well as a few poignant moments as
mallanna's animal sidekick hey hey the
rooster alan tudyk gets some lovely
comic scenes with a particular emphasis
on slapstick and after his roles and the
likes of big hero six frozen and
Zootopia is quickly becoming Disney's
equivalent of Pixar's good luck charm
John Ratzenberger and Rachael house is a
very welcome presence as mourn his
grandmother he brings some delightful
comedy as well as some cheeky wisdom to
the table Jemaine Clement may not get a
lot of screen time as a colossal bling
dirt crab Tama Toa but he makes every
second count giving a truly hilarious
scene-stealing turn that just oozes
genius comic timing oh and he gets a
brilliant David Bowie esque song called
shiny which he completely smashes as
well actually on the character front the
only thing that was a touch disappointed
with was that there wasn't more of
Mona's pet pig poet in the film
story-wise mana hits all the beats you'd
expect from this kind of quest based
plot about a young woman on a mission to
save her people but keeps things
interesting thanks to its appealing
characters and the way it draws on
Polynesian culture with veteran Disney
directors Ron Clements and John Wesker
on
it's hardly surprising that mallanna
takes on elements of some of their
best-known animations with a good dose
of the Little Mermaid and a little of
Aladdin but the directing Jiro and their
screenwriter Jared Busch who co-wrote
and co-directed the amazing Zootopia
also add inspiration from elsewhere
including Disney's Pinocchio and even
Mad Max fury road and if you're
interested in all of them one of Easter
eggs and references I have a video
coming up on that very subject the
formula from Alana's story may be tried
and tested but one of the things that's
refreshing about the movie is a fact
that compared to many of Disney's
princess based films there's absolutely
no love interest here so there's no
pining after princes or true love's kiss
from Anna just lots of adventuring on
the high seas in an effort to turn her
people's fortunes around before she
becomes their chief as far as its musics
concerned Moana is firing on all
cylinders
lin-manuel Miranda who created the hit
Broadway musical Hamilton
singer-songwriter oput AF ye who founded
the award-winning group to vaca and
composer Mark manthena have done a
cracking job creating a soaring
soundtrack infused with Polynesian
spirit through a rousing anthemic Tunes
rhythmic lyrical melodies jaunty
humorous tracks and more and a good many
of them a decidedly earworm e2 so expect
to be singing whistling or humming these
songs long after you've left the movie
theater in fact the film's music is so
strong that there's no doubt in my mind
that milena will be next on the list of
Disney movies adapted for the stage on
Broadway the West End and all around the
world in terms of hamurana compares to
Disney's other animations if your
favorite to the Zootopia and big hero 6
as of Disney's Mac catalog then this
return to the studio's more traditional
style of movie may not quite hit the
heights for you but if you're a fan of
films such as frozen then you're very
likely to feel right at home with this
new movie and if like me you like all
those films then you'll probably find
Moana very entertaining too by the way
if you are a big Disney fan whatever you
do make sure you keep your butt in your
seat right to the very end of the movies
credits as there is an X and that little
scene you won't want to miss and before
Moana kicks off you'll get the chance to
see a lovely new short film called inner
workings which is kind of an inside out
for our internal organs instead of our
emotions to sum up Moana is awash with
gorgeous anime
pitch perfect voice performances and a
superb soundtrack that you're very
likely to want to listen to over and
over again all of this as well as the
film's frequently funny moments it's
refreshing the interesting cultural
setting and the big smile it's very
likely to leave on your face make up for
the fact that on the story side Moana
treads fairly safe waters so I'm giving
Moana 4 out of 5 flicks now what did you
think of Moana and who are your favorite
Disney characters let me know in the
comments below
coming up I've got videos on the top 5
funniest moments in Moana
and all the Easter eggs and references
in the movie and you can click on the
links here to see those if you enjoyed
this video do share it and subscribe for
more movie reviews Easter eggs and crazy
movie and TV facts thanks for watching
and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers